hello everyone and welcome to the final
round of the trade wise Gibraltar chess
festival after ten rounds four players
went into tiebreaks
in the first round of the tiebreaks
eleven Iranian faced Richard rapport and
he defeated him to 2-0 first game
rapport lost with the white pieces
although he blundered in a position that
was definitely at least equal but maybe
even better and the second game of
course he had to go for a win with the
black pieces and that game of course are
another one as well in the second game
he cover Nakamura faced off with Maxine
Bashir la grand it took them four games
to decide the winner they didn't go into
Armageddon but in the end
Maxine Bashir managed to kick out Hikaru
Nakamura from the tiebreaks so this is
this is the final game of the tiebreaks
between Lebanon and the Maxine bar
sherrilyn Grove first two games were
drawn a third game was drawn and this is
Game four Oregon has the white pieces
and Maxime needs a draw for it to go to
the Armageddon so let's see this game as
it's quite interesting the lemon was
already very low on time in probably
after the opening so he played the
entire game after the opening like with
ten seconds on the clock it was like
really intense so d4 by Oregon and we
have Knight to f6 Knight to f3 g6 and
nights 2 C 3 D 5 by 2 F 4 and the
similar to the first game they played
when Aragon had the white pieces he went
III and H 4 here after Bishop to g7 he
decided to go for night to b5
immediately making some threats on the
c7 night to a6 defending the c7 pawn and
now III c6 Knight goes back to c3 and it
seems like this was a waste of time this
night b5 back to c3 but now this night
is very awkwardly placed on a6 and here
is a very good question should this
Knight stay on a6 or maybe maybe Knight
c7 should be playing maybe you shouldn't
allow white to capture this night with
the bishop to maybe defended with Queen
to b6 sorry MVL decided to go for
kingside castle and Aragon immediately
captured it
we have B captures and here we have h3
not allowing any Bishop to g4 ideas this
would be a good square for the bishop so
now the bishop doesn't really have any
good squares to be developed Knight to
d7 eleven castles and Bishop to be seven
now Knight to a4 preventing black from
pushing c5 but actually this is
something lemon said in an interview
after the game actually he thought that
MVL would play c5 here as after c5 you
don't really gain anything by capturing
upon here for example Knight captures
Knight captures D captures on c5 simply
rook to c8 and there really is no way to
defend this CC pawn so after this
c5 if MBL had played this maybe c3 and
that worked to see it like this is just
fine here a regardless of the doubled a
pawn but okay after Knight a four rope
to see it was played and now b4 and
making a very nice outpost for the
knight on c5 probably preparing to
exchange it for the night on d7 a5 here
we have night the c5 immediately
now wouldn't attack on the bishop on b7
that's undefended Knight captures
captures on c5 and here
Bishop to a6 playing it with a temple on
the rock and f1 so rook to e1 and now a
for preparing Bishop to b5 to create a
sort of a blockade Queen to d2
we have Bishop to b5 as planned and now
comes B for D captures on e4 rook
captures on e4 and Bishop to c4 now
Bishop to h6 here lemon wants to
exchange that we have Bishop captures
Queen captures and here is a very good
question how do you stop rook to h4 with
the threat of of course Queen captures
on h7 there is only one move that stops
this and MVL found it relatively quickly
he played f6 a nice way to blunder the
game would be to play f5 you play a five
and do you think that okay frog to h4
I'm gonna go rock f7 or no as well that
would be wrong because on f5 you be at
Knight to g5 and now there is again the
threat of checkmate
only way to stop it is to play rook to
f7 and after rook to f7 you simply
captured the rook and you can't capture
the rook on e4 because the queen is
attacked after King captures Queen
captures on h7 this comes with check and
black is falling apart so MV I played a
very nice move he played f6 stopping
both the threat of rook to h4 because he
has a rope to f7 and also this stops
Knight to g5 so nice to be to Rima
nuvaring the night and preparing to push
c4 after the bishop moves from c4 Bishop
to d5 attacking the rook rook e3 and now
comes Luke to b8 we have c4 Bishop to f7
and now again as now this Bishop is
blocking the rooks idea of rogue to f7
RNN goes rook to e4 defending the d4
pawn and also again threatening rook to
h4 so g5 stopping rogue to h4 rook 81
now doubling up on the e-file I'm that
east 7 pawn and here maxime probably
should have gone for either rook to b7
defending d7 pawn or a bit more active
move that is rook to be to going for the
night and D 2 that is undefended but he
played a 5 and he thought that this
actually prevents white from capturing
it if D captures then Queen capture some
D - the problem is Aragon captured upon
D factors on e5 and here's the problem
you can't capture on d2 because of he
captures on f6 and there is no way to
prevent Queen to g7 checkmate
not even to prolong it this is just
outright losing so after D captures on
e5 Bishop to g6 was played attacking the
rook but now simply rook for to the e2
defending the knight and all is well for
white rook to be 2 with a double attack
on the night here Knight to f3 now rook
captures rook captures and e F captors
on e5 and here rook captures on e5 you
don't want to play Knight captures only
5 if you play that then you get the
Queen to d1 check you lose the rook so
after F captures on e5 rook captures on
e5 Queen d1 check and King to h2 is
definitely a possibility Aragon decided
to go rook to e1 as he was extremely low
on time I think already here he was
below 10 seconds the time format if I
haven't mentioned this three minutes
plus two seconds increment so he
constantly has to play for those two
extra seconds Queen to c2 attacking the
c4 pon da to pawn also kind of harassing
that night the night would really enjoy
capturing or something but then you lose
the f2 pawn and here are in plate eight
three saving that a pawn not allowing
mvl to create any past pawns but this
was actually a great move as he really
saw it in a fraction of a second
another interesting move but not a great
move would be rook to e7 it seems like
this is threatening checkmate and it
seems like a very dangerous move but
after Queen c1 checked in King H - you
have Queen to f4 check now you either
have to move the King back allowing
again Queen to c1 check or you can block
this with g3 and of course not capturing
the night but simply Queen to f6 and
you're defending checkmate and white
really can't hope to make any progress
here in this position so after Queen c2
calmly Aragon played a3 it was as if he
had no idea he had like a couple of
seconds on his clock Queen captures on
c4 and now Queen captures and g5 finally
bringing the Queen into the game rook to
f5 we have worked - you need to check
and this was a very nice hit as the
bishop cannot capture the bishop is
pinned so King to g7 and now Queen to e7
with check King to h6 and now comes
Queen to e3 with check and it would be
very dangerous to go back with the king
if King to g7 then comes Knight to d4
attacking the rook and f5 oh this will
be with check and after Bishop captures
rook then comes Knight captures rook
this is with check also the Queen is
attacking now the bishop on e8
so if you don't want to be down a piece
you have to play King to f6 but now
comes Knight to d6 attacking the Queen
and this comes with a double attack on
the bishop on e8
so black is really without a move here
you have to block it but now comes the
night captures on e8 check King moves
now capture the Queen and it's all over
you're down a poem and the whole piece
this is completely winning for white
so after this Queen to e3 check of
course not kink the g7 and players saw
this in like really a fraction of a
second it was really really amazing
Queen to f4 blocking check and offering
a trade of Queens and okay you might get
some improvement on this 94 move
attacking the rook but like I said so
little time on the clock there wasn't
time for maneuvers like this so Aragon
simply captured we have rook captures
and now rook to e6 look to c4 and rook
captures on c6 and after all has found
down you see five points for 11 and 3
points for maxime and it seems a pawns
are doubled so it's a pretty much a
winning endgame but it was really really
all about the time will levin be able to
convert this with so little time on the
clock King to g7 Knight to e5 now
attacking the rook and the bishop
erupted the c1 check for king h2 and
Bishop to e4 attacking the rook on c6
rook to a6 given up the C pawn but the
a7 point will be captured with check so
rook captures first rook captures on a7
which check King moves and now Knight to
d7 attacking the rook rook to f5 and now
rook captures on a for attacking the
bishop bishop to c6 attacking both
tonight and the rock but rook to g4
check King moves and now Knight to b8
attacking the bishop and here
Maxine tried Bishop to b7 with the idea
that this will kind of limit the
movement of this Knight may be preparing
King to e7 and maybe maybe some King d8
to c7 and picking up tonight but
f3 here and not allowing the rook to
capture on f2 and here rook to B Phi was
played and this was the move that
basically finished the game here are
immediately found rook to before this
versus Maxime to exchange rooks if we
move the rook then of course rook
captures Bishop on b7 would check so he
had to exchange rooks here rook captures
on b5 a capture some b5 and in this
position magazine washer Allegra
resigned the game and 11 Iranian is the
2018 trade wise Gibraltar chess festival
winner why did he resign it seems that
black can maybe play King to e7 and now
it seems that the bishop and the King
are preventing this Knight from escaping
so maybe black could win this night and
maybe draw the game somehow
unfortunately it doesn't work white can
simply push a four here and after black
goes for the night
here comes b5 and now you have the c6
square available for the night and being
even if you win the b5 pawn they're
still two pawns up this is completely
winning so after this a capture some
before Maxime you resign the game and
after a long long day eleven onion is
the winner and he said in an interview
that you know he felt very sad because
in that round 10 against Hikaru Nakamura
he thought for a fraction of a second
that rook rook captures on h5 was
winning but in the end he had to draw
that game and he had to play like two
more games against Richard report and
then four more games against Maxime
Bashir to claim this title so yeah a
very very intense tournament and I do
hope you enjoyed the coverage as of
tomorrow I am returning to some old
classics from the 19th century and maybe
some of your favorite chess players like
Fischer towel are yakking and and such
so yeah I do hope you enjoyed it
I haven't found an interview with 11
after this game but as they'll probably
upload it so I will add it in the
description so you can enjoy it if you
haven't found it already and that's it I
would like to thank Timothy McCaskey for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it thank you all
for watching and I will see you soon
with some good old chess classics